i'm curious from your perception because
one of the things that he talks about in
the final message is that he feels that
he's been misunderstood and he takes
issue in particular with the fact that a
lot of the long-form content and the
long-form interviews that he does have
been chopped up they pull something out
they post it and it's not indicative of
what he's really saying because you're
making missing the preliminary context
you're missing what came after a lot of
times second and third parties will
insert different images and just
different videos in between his video
that changed the context entirely so i'm
just curious as someone who knows him a
little bit off camera and somebody who
also on camera has conducted these long
form interviews with him do you think
that what he's saying is accurate that
there's the andrew tate that you know
someone like you and then the andrew
tate that people see in these short
clips on tick tock wherever absolutely
absolutely in fact that's the direction
we've kind of gone i think in social
media primarily
i am known for doing long form
long format shows i just did a four hour
almost four and a half hour show um just
sort of uh describing and detailing
everything that i that i think has been
going on with andrew
and uh and of course you know summing it
all up in the in the ban and his
farewell message however i will say this
is that i have noticed this myself is i
have done
shows with people who uh want to do like
a a
they'll do a pre-record like they'll do
a zoom record and we'll do something
like a two hour
uh show maybe a two and a half hour show
and when you're working with
disingenuous people what they will do is
they will use that show for 30 second
buzz clips because right now we live in
the age or the generation i should say
of the tldr which is too long didn't
read
so that's that we have we have shorter
and shorter attention spans and when you
look at tick tock is you know in
particular right now you're looking at
anywhere between like say a 30 second 45
second maybe just under a minute buzz
clips and that's how people get their
news tick tock right now is the number
one way that that people are like
they're engaged more on tick tock than
anything else right now more than
instagram more than facebook more than
twitter more than any other social media
tick tock owns social media right now in
fact they own it so well that people go
to tick tock or maybe go to like twitter
or their social media to get their news
information they're not going to news
sites anymore they're going to tick-tock
to get it for for in a 30-second uh
ain't nobody got time for that format
and so what happens is that the the the
dynamic or the commercial interests or
the the the marketing interests play to
the shortest attention span right now so
i can go and do a two-hour video or i
can go and talk about certain things or
i can go and and uh go into detail same
thing with that you know andrew was
discovering you know over the course of
the last like six or eight months is
when he would go on these long-form
shows what would happen is people would
cut up those clips and turn it into
30-second like buzz clips
because that's how people consume that
media and what happens is then they only
see the very briefest moment of
something outrageous that he says
because that's what plays that's what
goes viral that's what gets like four
million views that's what gets the most
uh engagement because people will see
that and they want to talk about that
and i've been the i've been the subject
of that for quite some time now really
almost for a year and i've learned uh
kind of like the hard way i did um i did
an interview with uh michaela peterson
back in december of last year
about a two hour and 20 minute interview
and that was a pre-record she took about
uh two weeks to actually publish that
and now i know why because the moment
that that hit all of the buzz clips come
out at the same time just to
maximize the worst aspects of what i was
saying or what could have been
misconstrued because people know that to
build a brand right now it's all about
short attention spans it's all about the
30 second clip no ain't nobody got time
to go and look at a two-hour video i got
people in my my comments right now
saying i don't have time for a four four
four hour video so what content creators
such as myself do is we create clips
channels so we give like the most
salient clips or we we carve it into
time stamps is is
everybody wants immediate time stamps so
they can get to the part where they
think they're going to be most
interested then they go to short clips
and then we go to um
reels uh tick tock videos uh youtube
shorts anything that is under a minute
and even under a minute a minute is a
long time it's like 45 seconds is
probably about ideal right now so you're
only getting that one most outrageous
quote from that guy and that establishes
that guy's reputation whether it's me or
it's andrew or it's anybody else or
fresh and fit for that matter
particularly uh outrageous i guess is
this kind of stuff that i say or that
andrew says or that myron and fresh say
or anybody who happens to be in this
sphere when you take that and you put
that into an environment like tick tock
which by the way bans red pill content i
think uh myron and fresh are probably on
their like fourth or fifth account
some of the guys on rule zero with me
are on their like you know 12th or 13th
you know twitter account or or tick tock
account so it's it's it's really easy to
get banned just for one of those 30
second clips but if you're someone like
drew applewallow or something like that
and you're just putting like these
little kind of you know middle school
jobs and it's all you know insults and
everything that plays
but if you go on
tick-tock if you go on any social media
and you have some sort of hot take about
intersexual dynamics that's misogyny and
that will get you kicked off if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]